you're pretty offensive towards towards
a lot
and I'm not looking to be offensive I
really want to bring people together and
get these things done but the work I 100
I see your vision how do we do it
somebody you care well not don't say
Jewish media and Jewish Jewish
controlled media JM
like man you saw you sound like it it
sounds too much like 1930s Nazi Germany
that was leading up to the atrocities oh
he would say JM yeah he was a brand to
JM that's right no it's just the the the
implied like this um memified
uh
Prejudice towards a group in a way
that's going to lead to hate and I I
know you don't mean that I know I know
you have love in your heart you know as
a Prejudice towards a group that led to
hate
BLM
BLM took a black person
showed his death on camera
because okay
there are examples of
us being killed and being killed on
camera but if it was spread on camera it
was done on purpose by the media because
14 20 kids get killed in Chicago every
week and it's not spread that much they
like you said
singled out a person
directed everything on that person right
as the Martyr and
raise the people that hadn't had any we
didn't have our 40 acres of the mule we
didn't have you know like a lot of
things right like that black people have
not ever been given so once we've given
just a little bit like
your life matters right then we
literally like oh okay now we're being
heard
right but
actually the deaf toll is up the city uh
where this happened is completely been
turned to a war zone they actually
it's actually something like Candace
Owens can actually
specify this better but it's like its
own City or something like they they
made it not be a part of the actual
state or something that's like like DC
and stuff it's like it's like Washington
DC now and stuff like and that has to be
from a government
you know that's got
higher level agenda written all over it
yeah they're using the death of an
individual yeah sure the media are not
the Jewish media the media and that's
the media is [ __ ] up that machine
does takes whatever tragedy and uh
pushes it towards whatever narrative
that gets more clicks and Views and so
on sure and then politicians do the same
they use the media to influence the
media to tell a story and
um I this is a simple thing I put I
believe that
the idea of anti-Semitism and
the the closeness
of uh the Holocaust
is used by
certain individuals and media to not
take accountability for
the bad things that that are happening
and
what's happened is there's a new
frontier right meaning like it used to
be okay for somebody to be a billionaire
we thought about a billion a billionaire
right you a lot of times you think I'm
actually kind of being out of shape and
you know 20 years ago 30 years ago like
Onassis or something like you thought
about it different way now you think
about it but you think about Elon you
think Kim think yeah you think
it's a new kind of billionaire you know
it's not just Sorrows this is a
billionaire it's a new form of
billionaire we'll
right now what I'm calling for the
industry is I'm I'm calling I'm calling
the industry out and saying like hey it
just so happens that
there's been times where I had my lawyer
was Jewish my regular was Jewish but
like like eight people that basically
would collude and talk without me were
in groups saying okay this is what the
tour is going to be this is his next
house and they were making all these
decisions and they're making all this
money and at the end I was like I ended
my tour and I don't have the money and
it just so happens that that's the case
that what they were but what I'm saying
is if everyone can say
hey you can't point out this fact or
we're gonna say you're anti-semitic and
we're going to call you Hitler I feel
that there has to be at least one
percent of safeguarding the ability to
screw the artist based on saying it's
anti-semitic by pointing out that they
just so happened to all be uh Jewish
and I don't think that's anti-Semitism I
just think that's hey this is another
thing like okay the Kardashians when you
hear that do you think male or do you
think female
you think female you can say you think
this is the realities this is why rap
works right they're gonna make an
anti-women thing in a second right and
it's gonna say well if you point out
that these five women six women are
having a meeting on where the Christmas
party is and none of the ball players
are rappers that they have babies with
have any say so so that Christmas
happened at Courtney's house all eight
years when I was there and it never
happened at anyone else's black family
house right
if I'm the one that pointed it out they
just don't have they they don't have
their oh you're anti-semitic word to say
shut the [ __ ] up yeah because this is
the way it runs and this is the way we
want to do it if you say that though
that women are silencing the black voice
yes you're gonna get the same response
but especially if historically it's not
the fact that it's true
when you talk in groups
that breathes hay
when you talk about individuals it
solves problems you're an engineering
okay but this is something I pointed out
on Pierce I said if a black person gets
pulled over with a car and it's three
other people in the car they're also
going to jail they're not going to
single them out they're going to say you
guys are all in collusion I just
describe collusion five times in this
interview
and you keep on going back to this is
like 1930. this is like this this is
like that what I'm saying is look I want
to work with you as an engineer to free
my people can we start as a being with
engineer opportunities right here I I am
sorry to the people who had to be hurt
and affected by that now we are here and
I'm looking to solve it but what happens
is every time if I talk to any of these
business people one by one because mind
you I didn't get to the Tweet by not
having a conversation I had the
conversations beforehand before I got to
the Tweet now we gonna take it to the
stage now we're on the world stage right
and you saw Ari Emmanuel do exactly the
kind of thing that I was saying have
been done behind closed doors now he's
doing it and open doors they told
Candace Owens I couldn't be on the daily
wire like you can't even explain
yourself
and we don't care have how you got to
that point either and that's [ __ ] up
they told Kansas you can't be understood
yes you did that's what they said and
you know what and you can have my voice
raised or lower I'm gonna do it lower
right because what's happening to me by
I put in your words the media is saying
not only
can you not explain yourself we don't
care how you got to that point you need
to apologize and you can't explain and
that's the end of the story so just
apologize so we can have Mel Gibson do
some more films
is exactly what Ari Emmanuel was saying
no one is looking to change the problem
that led so many people to that same
level of frustration and I just so
happen to be the one that's not going to
back up on it until this changes because
you know what I'm sorry I had a sleepy
text I'm sorry I would I'm sorry for
everything I'm sorry that I I put uh
that I was uh 5 12 or 511 on uh Tinder
okay my [ __ ] is not 14 inches I lied
okay it's only 13. yeah so I'm sorry
right so the
oh he's dropping so many facts today so
what I'm saying is but where do we get
to this because even you as engineering
as intelligent as you are you just like
everyone else that I was saying was
colluding won't let us get to the point
of fixing it yeah but I'm not I think
you're more powerful than the media I'm
not saying you need to apologize because
the media I'm saying everything we've
been talking about just because I care
for you and I want you to be the best
possible man you can be to me a
definition of a great man I'm with
Martin Luther King on this you don't
talk about Jews or or black people you
talk about engineering you talk about
Humanity you solve problems you identify
the problems in the world and you don't
come from a place of resentment this
group did this this [ __ ] all that that
is in the past you just build Solutions
I'm going to create a new record label
I'm going to create a new design firm
I'm going to create a new Social Network
I'm going to do better I'm going to do
it right I'm going to do it right by the
people that I know don't have a voice
I'm gonna give them a voice and talk
about that is it okay to call out
collusion do people collude in your
business under you like like the
engineers they come together and like
say they collude against the bosses
right you know why Bernardino offered
the deal and took it away from me
collusion
because I was too powerful but the
collective that I had right there he had
to stop that at all costs they said for
whatever reason this kid yay it has the
ability to have all of the Kardashians
Jay-Z and Beyonce uh Justin Bieber dimna
Virgil due to all these people in the
same room working towards the same goal
I've been that person
since preschool that's called a leader
right and right now what I'm saying is
hey
for the people in business whatever
their background is whether they turn
their whether they turn their cell
phones off on Friday or not
there's been some bad business done
there's some bad business practices and
we have to change that because
this game is like boxing more people end
up [ __ ] than rich
and I'm saying like beat to a pope
Driven Crazy beat by the media to a pope
right now the media has done everything
they could to make me apologize and to
make me look crazy and that one person
has done anything to find out why I was
frustrated enough to do that tweet and
that's facts and that's [ __ ] up
well I I was hoping to I am finding out
we found out I mean but like I want
Solutions like see there's something
about human nature where if you focus
too much on resentment we're not
focusing on anymore [ __ ] the results man
we're moving forward